[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
with a local ltp audits during that time
of year
so so from a resourcing perspective we
won't have any
shortages of resource of resources to
come and assist with the ltp
audits again i think we
are focusing on to start ltp audits
probably late november early december
right through to
to june next year so that that is not
impacting on
on that time frame
um i guess i guess the question to start
for to mr milward and mr palmer is
noting what we've been advised to view
any concerns about our ability
to meet our indicated ltp deadlines
uh no i don't have any concerns at this
stage we haven't
amended the order plan still expected to
take place
the majority of it in september so we're
on track to adopt the annual report
sorry um in october
and the ltp uh pcg is a little bit
behind
at the moment but it will soon catch up
as derek
has mentioned there's quite a lot of
documentation that they'd want to view
over that period of time one's the
asset management plans and currently
we're doing that concurrently with the
ris strategy but that's a pretty normal
case is what happens and we usually have
an agreement with the audit that
if we identify anything significant that
comes out of those
uh renewals of the reviews or the asset
management plans we
signal those so now i don't have any
concerns over the time frames we're
pretty much on track we've completed
most of our
revaluation of our assets some of the
most significant ones are the other
three waters they've gone up about 24
which has a flowing effect for rating
roading we always do each year because
we're a growth council
and we have an impact on the road usage
so we always have a significant
significant movement there which we
account for annually
our most significant movement has
probably been within our interest rate
swaps
the hedging that we do for for our debt
where it's moved about five million
dollars so
um yeah we're pretty much on
target we've still got some investment
property to get confirmations on
uh but very much uh on on timetable
yeah and yeah i'd concur with what
uh jeff has said um
my assessment is that the year in
valuation adjustments as a result of
covert uh relatively immaterial to our
business
based on what we know today in terms of
either
collectibility of values or underlying
asset value
changes in terms of commercial property
or the like i think those
risks are relatively low low for us
and timetabling
understand what you're saying that your
priorities are going to be driven by the
auditor general's priorities so if that
says resource directed away from our
audit somewhere else then
uh that may impact your ability to issue
an opinion
in the time frames that we'd hoped for
if that
we obviously want to keep in touch with
you about that if that were the case
um i think accountability is important
and we would probably
consider if that was going to be a
significant delay whether we actually
adopted an unaudited
set of accounts at some point and made
those publicly available
and came back and received an ordered
opinion at a later time if there was
going to be a significant delay but
we can talk to you about that um uh
the the balance of the audit to
or the preparation of the financial
statements to my knowledge is
tracking as we would expect so i think
we will be able to meet our commitments
but it'll be important to stay closely
connected to you
in terms of your resources and
availability as well
thank you and class obama
and just following on and thank you for
um advising of the 1.5 percent
rate increase because that was something
i was going to query um
obviously this council has received some
excellent audits going through and we
seem to have
had a good track record and audits is
there not in the future
a consideration of doing a lighter audit
for councils for for good behaviour
for those who've actually had some good
credit and and have actually shown to be
managing their finances responsibly
to perhaps give them a little bit is the
audit general actually considered
anything like that
yes thank you um i think from our
perspective
we would love her like to audit
[Laughter]
um yeah unfortunately we our audits are
driven by
also standards that is legislated
so the legislation says we must audit in
terms of
the auditing standards and that auditing
standards prescribes
what we need to do so there's a lot of
almost
i don't want to say thick box but you
have to tick all the boxes you know so
i have done this i have done this and i
think with with a lot of
um corporate collapses in recent times
it just has just made that a lot more
onerous
um you know so i think the expectations
on the auditor
has increased significantly um
even from just from the
recent covert pandemic experience
uh a lot of if you speak to a lot of
auditors the
expectation increased work is around 20
to 30 percent
just as a result of that which is very
unfortunate
because of all the assumptions and
judgments that now needs to be
considered and scrutinized
to the nth degree and and
that's unfortunately the the reality and
then the environment in which we
which we operate um but i mean i take
the point that yes i think
council has been doing quite well in
recent times
we are trying to focus on the key risk
areas
and and not waste time on the areas that
that you are doing well in
and ensuring that we can still add value
through the process subsequent
question then to mr palmer um has that
ever been considered
in your experience of order to actually
and
my rule is if there's if there's a law
that's not working you try and fix the
law
so is there been representations to the
auditor general
about the the
in-depth nature of audits or what audits
could be considered for local
authorities
it has been a topic that's been raised
over probably decades to be fair
um and
and the scope of
the
several comments firstly in terms of
there's a legislative obligation to
undertake an audit so that
while the auditor general might have a
view about the merits of the audit at
the moment that sits within the local
government act about
particularly ltps and the nature and
extent of audit the audit considerations
as soon as there is a requirement to
undertake an audit
auditors have an obligation to meet the
relevant auditing standards
so that automatically drives auditors
to discharge any audit in accordance
with those standards
and the institute and
other bodies are now including the iag
put quite a lot of pressure on or
focus on auditors meeting
audit standards which
in my view the risk-based approach
awarded
is being lost in the mix
and a lot genuine risk
uh as opposed to compliance so a lot of
the auditors now
come has a in my view a high degree of
compliance
associated with it and i'm not blaming
our auditors for that that is
that is just needing to meet some audit
standards which
have been driven out of corporate
failure across the
world and audits previously not having
drawn those to attention
in my view the approach to the audit of
public sector audit
versus audits in the commercial sector
and particularly where going concern
and issues of viability are very much to
the forefront of audits and
those who rely on those statements
should be should be getting a
thorough consideration of those key
risks i think some of our
audit in public sector is
not as well aligned as it could be and
that
i know the auditor-general's aware of
those issues but
being aware of it and being able to
change that is is not necessarily the
same thing so
um the auditor general's not immune to
that risk either and
there wasn't there was there was a
situation some years ago related to
kuiper where the auditor general was
actually
uh sued in respect of whether
that audit undertaken was of sufficient
quality so that
that's put the auditor general on on
notice about
the quality of their audit particularly
around ltps and
valuation risks so
yes i think i think there should be a
reframing of the way
public sector audit is undertaken so
that it adds more value
focuses on the genuine major risks and
has less of a compliance focus
so that they are my observations but i'm
not i'm
not uh certainly laying any of that at
all at new zealand's door uh while they
might be able to influence that they
they as soon as undertaking an
engagement are obliged to follow audit
standards and if they don't then
derek and his team expose themselves to
a reasonable amount of
uh risk to their credibility and
professional standing so that's
you know i'm not not suggesting that
they deviate away from that but it's a
more of a systemic issue
that i think a mature conversation
should be had
but when when derek might be able to
comment on that but i'm
but i don't blame audit new zealand
for the work that they need to do to
meet their audit standards
thank you
any further questions councils
so the mayor moves we've got
recommendations um
we received the report agreed to
the engagement arrangements and audit
plan for the year ending
june 30th 2020 and we note
the fee is within our budget forecast
so the mayor's moved and councillor
barnett has seconded
um do we have any discussion please look
look thank you both um derek and trevor
for being with us today and as you
note from my questions the concern
that's coming from
within our sector around time frames i
accept
um that there are resourcing issues that
have been raised and around time frames
but
i would have thought that um given that
we are in a captive environment
and we are as my understanding we don't
have a choice where we're audited
that uh that that i think that it's been
well known that our long-term plans are
coming around and i think that the
auditor-general should
make sure that we are prioritized as a
sector in that respect and realize
there's other work going on too but
it's a very important measure to our
community that our accounts are properly
audited
and that's why we spend the resource
that we do with all the new zealanders
no reflection on yourselves but i think
it's a matter that the auditor general
does need to carefully reflect on there
was a fair degree in
naval accounts lack and some all the
tests there was a fair degree of concern
raised at
our sector last week about this very
topic
and that's why a number of deputations
went off um to see the autism general in
that space
i personally want to see us meet our
deadlines i don't want to see us go out
with
not all non-audited accounts
to our public because it's a very
important measure but in saying that i
agree to the
us continuing our arrangements we've got
a very good relationship with all that
new zealand but
i think it's important for us to raise
our concerns with you
and for those to be reflected back to
the auditor general thank you
thank you yes similarly i see
huge value in having the audit it
certainly highlights our processes and
it helps us to tidy up areas
that may just pose a little bit of risk
to the the council
and to the community so we need to do
this it certainly adds value and
credibility
and my questioning and no no respect um
reflected on audit new zealand at all
um but i do believe that uh we have
moved away from actually doing an audit
that adds value and having
have more of a tick box audit at times
which if
a private sector a public sector entity
has been performing well
i believe should perhaps mean that you
don't have to do quite as much as you
would do
for an entity that maybe is having a bit
of trouble so i do believe there is a
another conversation to be had in that
space where a risk-based approach
would actually make much more sense for
a public sector entity
private sector is quite different and to
apply the same rules to both
doesn't seem to make sense to me we want
our audit to be transparent
and fair and focus on the areas of high
risk so that we know that we're steering
the ship in the right direction
and i think that's something that
perhaps the mayors could take up also
with the auditor general going forward
and so that was the line of my
questioning but i thank you very much
i know that we are in budget and i
appreciate very much
that you have kept your costs to the 1.5
which actually
coincidentally matches our rate rise for
the financial year
thank you any other comments councillors
all right we'll put that recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
against the clear it carried thank you
thank you very much um thank you
yes i've just got maybe one or two
comments around the ltp
uh if i might um
yeah so um as my indicator that there
was a session out last week so there is
still a lot happening in the background
around
um ltps so that process is is happening
and
um our auditors are being acquainted
with all the expectations around
what is quite the themes for this for
this ltp round and i think that would
have been shared
with um with management and and those
that attended that session but
maybe again for those that that weren't
at the session you know i think that
they're
phrasing it the four or five c's um
which is which is the key critical areas
that you need to be focused on
is around covet 19 again you know the
assumptions that
to what extent does this impact your
longer term view
um around climate change is another area
that
is gaining a lot of prominence because
again we saw from
previous ltps that although recognized
that it is an issue
maybe didn't get quite the voice that it
needed to
in and reflected adequately in the ltps
and to see to what extent your assets
um are susceptible to changes
in climate um you know how can it
actually weather the storm
and what are the assumptions around
climate change that that impacts
on your assets the other theme that's
coming through
is around your capital projects because
again from past experience
and from looking at councils across the
board
we saw that only up to a maximum of 80
percent
of capital projects or funding of
capital projects are being spent
so again it puts into question the
reasonableness
of capital projects and that expected
spending
which then puts the oltp and your
long-term
processes into question
so that that's another key focus area to
make sure that
your capital project estimates
and expenditure budgets are robust and
that you are able to deliver on those
capital projects
and the others see is around just your
consultation documents
again to make sure that that the
consultation documents isn't
a mini ltp that it's there to
consult with the community so that is
again something that we that we will be
looking at
there's a lot of um bulletins and
information that will be made available
on our website
uh ours and the office of the auditor
generals throughout
the next couple of months that can
assist
councils in ensuring that these critical
areas are
looked at properly and accounted for in
your ltps
so again i think there's a lot happening
in the background to
again assist in in laying any fears
around
not meeting those legislative deadlines
in ensuring that you can meet
and and for us to meet those required
time frames when it comes to the ltp
so maybe just those fighting remarks
thank you thank you thank you committee
thank you all right
indeed we'll see you again
okay we'll move on to item 5.2
which is um a report on the healthy
health and safety annual plan and
proposed 2021 plan and welcome
charlotte if you want to take us
through your report um
thank you and good morning everybody i'm
here on behalf of
liz ashton to present to you our
annual achievements against agreed
health and safety
2019-2020 annual plan
which was presented in the report of
note
is the carryover of two of the major
projects due to
um essentially there was delay due to
covert 19
um in one particular project and then
also
with the support to the rangiora service
centre
corporate accommodation project
obviously there has been um
overall project changes covert 19 and
then the recent
engineering assessment changes which has
meant that that has also been carried
over to this year's annual plan
additionally the report presents other
activities and statistics
relevant to our health and safety
performance in particular those leading
and lagging indicators
each of the data have been presented
within
either the health and safety report that
is presented to council on a monthly
basis the
due diligence report or in individual
reports that have come to the audit and
risk committee
based on audits that have been
undertaken during the year
so none of those data are new
however i'm happy to discuss any of
those further
and then has also presented the health
and safety work plan or
annual plan for 2020
2021 um other than that i will
take the oh sorry and in addition
beyond what has been presented in the
report of note
is that obviously during the covert 19
response and lockdown the health and
safety team
in particular provided a great deal of
well-being response
during that time and also have made
significant input into that
recent rain or a service centre
engineering assessment response
and this will lead into our assistance
in the rangira service centre corporate
accommodation project this coming year
other than that i will take the report
as being read and happy to respond to
any questions
any questions counselors of charlotte
councillor redwood oops
thanks for the report charlotte on page
paragraph 1.7.2
um i just wanted a view to elaborate on
those matters which refer to bullying
fatigue
work related strengths and so on
so is that sort of a culture
issue or is that an issue oh and the
annual plan that is coming up
is that correct sorry uh that's a
summary on
diligent page 72 i'm not sure what page
it is on yours
uh page four oh yes sorry uh
1.7.2 yes
so increase and focus on the risk areas
um
regarding bullying fatigue and
work-related stress that's correct and
we work
uh quite closely with the hr team in
particular who take the lead
on that in regards to
bullying and harassment policies and
processes that
go on and also
in regard to fatigue management so
working closely with units
to ensure that fatigue management
processes are adhered to
so particularly in areas where there is
um
emergency response in particular is
where we find that fatigue management is
becomes quite a risk
if i could just follow up to what degree
is that an issue
to what degree is it initially is it an
issue here um it came out as
as one of the key risk staff are
indicating that as an issue
rather than necessarily us auditing and
finding it as an issue
so that's come through in the online
safe plus assessment that we did earlier
in the year
and so where people are being asked to
indicate which risks they
they see as being the the greatest risks
within the organization that those are
the ones that are coming through as
as greatest risks councillor atkinson
being minimum chair i know in the um bar
graph on i think it's your page 73 yeah
page 73
and then again in the statistics on 74
the near miss um that it's actually
decreased
um reporting on on near miss which is
the bit we want to grow
in any health and safety plan we want
the near misses reported as opposed to
anything else
why is that that it's actually going
down as opposed to up
because i don't believe it's because
people are avoiding more near-misses no
that's correct uh one of the things that
we did do this year we had
actually captured um incidents that were
now called um adverse interaction and
adverse interactions into the near
misses previously
um and so i've i can't remember exactly
the date that we
we changed that but we decided that that
particular um
incident type was of significance enough
to be
to have its own incident type so that's
pulled some of the
the near misses out in a sense um
other than that yes we probably i would
like to see more near misses
reported definitely yes
thank you council award
um i just like to go back to the fatigue
issue
is is could some of that be due to the
tight
working conditions that the staff are
experiencing
no and um and also i note that
we're actually working in 12 different
buildings right now
that can't be very good for the
well-being of the staff
look i'm pleased you've highlighted
uh issues of
work fatigue and
i would my observation is that the
organisation is actually quite
tired and there's there are probably
levels of stress
for some people that are higher than
would be
desired we have annual leave balances
which are far
higher than we would like right across
our organisation and that's not a
healthy
indicator either so i
certainly covert has added
stress it's created uncertainty and i
think we all face that uncertainty about
what covert
um has both uh impacted has had on us
and it's not only just workers but it's
also
um whanau of workers so
may not be our staff who are impacted
but a partner or
a brother sister mother daughter some
they they they they all add to our
overall well-being and if things aren't
right at home
for one reason then that's often gets
transferred or manifests itself in the
workplace as well
um certainly the issue we've had with
round euro service center
has been less than helpful in that space
as well and
has compounded that so i i think you're
right to
acknowledge some of those issues we have
being across multiple sites
isn't desirable and a number of working
from home which
some like and some would prefer to be in
the workplace and we try and accommodate
those needs as best we or
concerns as best we can but i i think
i think and also just
uh if we're in a cycle where this time
of the year
is the time of the year people you know
winter actually just
uh just gets everybody that extra inch
down as well which uh
you know when you actually start to come
into spring you actually see people
start to have a little bit of a bounce
in their step but
uh right this month um is about is about
as low as
it gets in that space as well so yeah
there are a number of things which are
which do present themselves in various
ways for staff and
we've got we we have a very good um
employee assistance program through ea
support eap support
and um and our
human resources and health and safety
team are really good at supporting and
helping people through issues so and
they are and you are getting a number of
those people coming to you with those
concerns so
it is a you are right to identify it as
an issue for us
and further to that um i think one of
the things that has happened it
has been an extremely stressful time
a lot of people have worked very hard
over the past six months
in particular over the covert 19
lockdown and responses to various things
that have happened
over the year that have been unforeseen
um i think that probably
also we know that we need to in a sense
do more with less
or do more with the same amount of
resources that we have so it is
something that needs to sit
at the front of our minds in terms of
ensuring that staff
staff fatigue levels are managed
appropriately
my sense is that fatigue is something
that precedes
significant harm so where you have
somebody who is fatigued who
is driving or operating machinery or
doing anything of any um with any great
risk level which we have some
staff in our almost a lot of our staff
in our organization who are field
workers
or who are dealing driving heavy
machinery or who are driving vehicles
um it is something that needs to be
front of mind in particular as a
precursor to serious harm
just a question then uh mental
well-being worries me the most i think
at this stage because it's
often the invisible um problem
um is there anything else we could
initiate
um as a council to improve staff morale
some sort of
activities or rather than having to make
people go and talk about their problems
but often distraction can be a wonderful
thing
something to look forward to is there
something being considered about to
improve staff morale
um i'm quite proud of the work that we
do around in the well-being space
in terms of trying to ensure that people
are
connected with each other and uh and
have the
events and occasions that they may need
to have in order to kind of
lift their morale and well-being we do
have a strategy which is based around
the five ways to well-being
and essentially so connecting is
obviously one of those really important
things
ensuring that we're making that that
people get
physical and mental health support
things like the long-standing mad
committee and the social club are
incredibly important to our
well-being strategy beyond that yes
there's always more we could be doing
um but i think that from an
organisational perspective things like
as jim mentioned the
our eap so workplace support we've also
got a great peer support
program which allows people to actually
go and talk to
another staff member who is potentially
more at their level or who they have a
connection with
we have a number of staff who are kind
of almost
i suppose in a sense front line as as
jim mentioned was
you know the health and safety team and
the hr team do take a lot of that
that i suppose those first queries
um other than that yeah there is always
more that we could potentially do but i
am very proud of the work that is done
by the med committee by the social club
and by the well-being committee in this
space
and i would concur with charlotte i
i think we have
we have quite a range of opportunities
and actually it's often a sign of
you know well-being we're we're actually
struggling sometimes for volunteers for
our social club and mad committee
and and we put on events and sometimes
they're not that well attended and
actually that's often a
a signal that people are actually you
know you actually get to friday night
and all you want to do is go home
not socialize with your colleagues or do
uh extracurricular type activities so
but trying to trying to you know trying
to keep the mood of the organization
light and um you know there is plenty to
be thankful about
we're not very you know being
appreciative is
one of the important things in this time
of actually saying thank you to people
and
probably as an organization we've got
an a type personality which is well we
forget about that we've just done that
and completed that what's the next task
we don't celebrate
particularly well as an organization you
know we've just had an accomplishment
this week announced but you know
our stoic response to that is yep that's
good now what do we need to focus on to
improve
um uh and so that's you know
and i accept responsibility because i
lead a lot of that behavior
um as well so you know we we probably
need to you know we need to be kinder to
ourselves and there are a couple of
externalities
on the horizon that you're all familiar
with in terms of either sector reform
and ltp pressures
and the like which are going to mean
that we're
there there is no immediate let up in
the in
what's coming at us so we do need to be
thinking about
what we can reasonably expect our
organization to deliver hand still
whole hold the plastic thing around all
the cans all the time
so yeah thank you to that mr palmer so
what are we doing to to celebrate the
double a rating across the organisation
is that being considered at the nothing
apart
apart from the um the warm feeling we
have inside we've done nothing to
celebrate that and that's a reasonable
question to us
um
i'll reflect on that
any more questions counselors just
before you move to the bank and i just
acknowledge charlotte uh this is uh
charlotte's last time
uh with this committee she she she's
attended her resignation
from the council and um 31st of july
is her last day we're extremely
appreciative and proud of the efforts
that charlotte has
delivered in the particularly in the
health and safety but more recently in
quality
and risk management had a huge workload
and
one of those a type personalities as
well with a long list and
boy she's plowed through it and made a
significant
contribution to how well we are regarded
in terms of our health and safety
practices
and you've made a big difference to our
organisation i just like
the committee if as part of its
uh motion if it thought appropriate to
include thanks for charlotte's
contribution which
has been huge thank you
yeah thank you and undoubtedly the
deputy mayor is very
keen to add that too it's actually going
to be part of my opening yeah
but however
councillor atkinson moves in the near
seconds of councillor atkinson
thank you cheer um i'll just
actually do what uh what jim has said
because he said it very eloquently and
uh and charlotte has moved our organized
into an
organisation into a space that is is
fantastic going forward and it's a big
step and it's always critical
you know you've got people sitting
around the table or my generation who
are of the
harden up and get on with it category
and that's inter-generational to change
it doesn't happen overnight
and a lot of us don't like what happens
in the health and safety space but it's
something that we
we have to deal with and change our mind
i'm one of the people who were actually
very appreciative of calls from our
staff while we were locked in
the lock down and cover to actually ask
where his elected members were getting
on i don't think i've
ever had that asked of me of anybody or
actually no not true graeme ford once
during the earthquake
dropped off some muffins and said your
elected members get forgotten about them
what you do
so the second time it's actually
happened
that someone's actually running wrong to
see how you're going
what it did for me was actually sparked
me to ring some of my constituents
particularly in the business world and
say to them how you going
you know what's happening knowing that
they had
people that they had to deal with in
exactly that space you've just been
talking about
which is that fatigue and pressure and
stress space of knowing whether they
did or didn't have jobs when they came
back and and hopefully
that made a bit of a difference to them
moving out and
talking to their people as well so i
think charlotte's made a fantastic
difference to this organisation and that
in that space um health and safety
i think that uh it is charlotte
explained that
hopefully those two figures match up
between the near misses and the
i can't remember the heading you called
it hopefully they do match up into
more near-misses because i mean the more
near-misses we have reported the less
accidents we have
and the more reactive we can be about it
so it's actually a space
on here in the graph that i look at
every time because that is the big one
that really does make a difference to
people not getting injured at work
and what you do about it so i i look
forward to that
um going through um celebrations i
i was also going to bring that up we
were
both the mayor and i were congratulated
by many people actually and
thursday and friday asked by the ceo
himself of local government new zealand
what it is you're going to do about it
or you're just going to sit on it
and we did reflect on the fact that jim
was very conservative when it comes to
celebrations because he doesn't like
getting knocked off the
top perch but i
feel that it is somewhere we need to go
and again with our staff every time we
achieve something
you know this is a a whole organisation
um win the so this uh this uh
mark and i think that it needs to be
celebrated and they are the things that
will
bring our organization into a much
better place
and actually show our public that we
don't just sit here
and talk and make up rules and do things
we actually do them for the good
of the people in which we represent
thank you i've thoroughly endorsed those
comments and especially
um acknowledging you charlotte for
i think a fantastic contribution you've
made to this organisation since
certainly since i've observed the
improvements we've made in this space
you're very clear
um and your processes are excellent and
i
look we're really sad to see you go but
celebrate what you've done here
and also wish you well on your journey
to your next part of your career
so you go with um goes obviously with
our best wishes but
tinge tinsburg sadness because we never
like to lose somebody that's made the
contribution that you have here and it
will be lasting through the processes
and things that you've put in place so
go well yeah um
just in in general i look endorsed the
comments been made
um councillor um atkinson then and
through the questions of council ivana
here
um i do look up around the building
probably a lot more than other elected
members and i
i do observe a very good spirit that
exists
and i think that the work that we do
internally and we can never rest on our
laurels but
the surveys that are in place um there's
plenty of opportunities in which for
people to
let the organisation know how they're
going that's not to say that we don't
have pressures because we do
council awards right to observe the
building there's a fair amount of
anxiety around the place about it in
fact there's a lot of anxiety
in the community who've asked me
repeated questions oh you're out of your
building
and you're not in your space and to
explain to them that that's not actually
how it is but
um there are there are those things the
clear lines of communication
and keeping people informed with what we
know is important and i
commend to see in our staff for the
clear lines of communication that do
exist
i think that was one of the things that
marked through covert and it's one of
the
things that was regularly reflected back
to me how much people
um respected jim um for his leadership
through that time the regular
communication
the funnies that existed that came out
most days we missed those actually jim
but they were um it was just a very real
part of the communication
i really appreciated liz reaching out to
me to see her i was doing which was
really kind she
needed to do that but it was very nice
of her just to see her i was
doing so i think the dots were connected
in many ways
through that time but we do need to be
very mindful
of the signs that are existing it
certainly are a lot of people very
stressed at the moment and
some of those we're starting to see so
as an organisation
we certainly need to be mindful of that
i'm very proud of our council for the
double a
it's an amazing achievement um to be
reaccredited with that we're one of two
councils in the country too have
achieved double a
yes we do need to celebrate that i have
it on my list to talk to
jim about it um i was going to discuss
it yesterday but we had a few other
things to talk about
so we will do something um for that i
would like to see us celebrate it in
some way how we'll do that i'm not sure
about at the moment but
have a discussion with jim about that
but it should be acknowledged and
celebrated
we've certainly put a press statement
out around that so our community will be
aware of that but
um to to have that endorsement um uh to
have that reflection from
from an external um provider is
fantastic
so just goes it goes to the health
and what of our organisation but here
we're focused on the health and safety
and
and the work that's there so thoroughly
endorse the report
and um thank you for the work again
charlotte that you have done in this
space
thank you councillor yes um thank you
very much for an excellent report
charlotte and it will be very sad to see
you guys
um i won't repeat the comments but
they're certainly echoed around the
whole committee by the side of it
um leap staff is staff are our biggest
asset
and so therefore they're also one of our
biggest risks and this committee
has to deal with risk um if when staff
leave
it not only causes cost for us
and it opens up risk and we lose um
experience we lose resourcing
and that's very very difficult for the
organization and
it's the whole process that we have to
go through so i think it's really really
important that this committee
is very aware that we do have adequate
resourcing
that we are able to manage their risk
and that we are
able to manage the look at succession so
i would appreciate perhaps a little bit
more information in that space going
forward from the wooden wrist
perspective um
we saw with anxiety from the earthquake
times
that a lot of people react by shutting
down
and they don't talk to anybody so you
can have all the
beautiful programs available which we do
but some people will never reach out
and that's it that's difficult because
what do you do for those people
and often it is the contact with a
co-worker
or the smile or a shared morning tea
that actually can make the difference
in another organization i worked for
when someone went above and beyond
they just got a voucher for subway so
they could go and get a free subway
um it's amazing what a free coffee or a
free subway voucher can make someone
feel very valued or appreciated
so there's not major cost in actually
recognising and celebrating
successes and effort from our staff
there is a huge cost when we lose stuff
and so therefore um i i would encourage
mr palmer and the team to look at that
very very seriously going forward
because we need to keep our staff they
are absolutely brilliant
they've been working very very hard and
we couldn't have got through
many of these emergencies and disasters
that we've faced
in the last 10 years without them thank
you
any other comments no
i'd just like to add um my
congratulations to you
charlotte for an excellent job um over
your
court here and wish you really well for
your future
so um
i'm sorry no no all right
we'll put it um all those in favor
please say i
against declare it carry thank you very
much
good luck right we move on to item
5.3 which is
the quarterly status report on our cyber
security
and welcome owen to take us through that
over to you
so um good morning everyone um this is
an update on the cyber security
this is an action we take with the
audience committee on a quarterly basis
that's recommended um as good practice
as following up from an external
assessment that we undertook
um so this quarter we are still on
progress with us
um our action plan we have produced an
action plan for cyber security
that has been impacted by um by covert
and lockdown
and some of the uncertainty around the
buildings so we have had to
reassess a lot of what we're doing to
try to
provide better ways of working for our
staff
we have however managed to produce some
some improvements during this quarter
and we are still on progress to provide
an improved
score against our association of local
government information managers
our game framework that we score
ourselves against
during this quarter we have introduced
for all for our staff primarily um
multi-factor authentication for our for
the emails and we have
also doing the lockdown provided the
cyber security training
um so that's been rolled out as part of
our mimecast they have rolled out seven
short videos
and some corresponding quizzes for staff
and we have provided a report
on the back of that to show that there
has been a positive uptake of that and
the the general consensus from staff has
been
that it is a positive thing and that
they have enjoyed them
um we are going to be extending that out
to elected members as well
so that will be rolling in our times as
you mentioned in the previous meet with
you guys
um some improvements to the elected
members
the ability to log on and also we're
looking at rolling out
some cyber security training to elected
members as well
that will hopefully provide coverage
across most of the stakeholders of the
council that
that log in and that provides security
to our organization
we're also currently using um something
called pro map which is the risk
management tool that
has been introduced to track cyber
security risks
um we have 10 tracking at the moment and
we have mitigations in place for all
those and we have plans in place
to obviously kind of mitigate those
through our our cyber security plan and
uh
some of the argument improvements that
we're doing as well
um we so we have now moved our
mail system to an external mail system
with microsoft
that removed a little bit of risk that
we had in place around
the ability to log on using um something
called webmail
so that is now sitting in a data center
in
in sydney at the moment so we have
improved that
and we have also been um rolling out a
tool that allows us to
monitor our networks and monitor the the
activity of staff
um around cyber security so we have
proved some improvements over the last
quarter
uh which have been repo which have been
reported back against the argent
framework
this is a self self monitored framework
we will be at the end of the year
undertaking a review
externally to see how we are progressing
um with our game
um but we are at the moment progressing
well we are providing improvements and
we are still tracking ahead of most
other other councils that are reporting
against the argument framework as well
um we are reviewing
up some of our software at the moment um
as part of the the improvements that
we're making
so we're reviewing our anti-virus
security at the moment
um we're looking at changes to our the
way that we monitor wear boxes for staff
and we're also one of the improvements
that was a key to our improvements was
to look at
redesigning our network this has been
delayed uh because of us being out of
the office because of some of the
improvements to office but we have
actually managed to sign some of our
contracts around that
and we will be progressing ahead with
that to redesign our network as well
um we are aiming as i mentioned to carry
on keeping improvements over the
of the quarter and again at the end of
the year we will be having
an external review and an external
vulnerability review as we do every year
to provide
provide feedback against how we've
progressed
at the moment our biggest risk is still
our users
so that's why we're providing our
security awareness training around that
we will be extending that training
to incorporate something called phishing
training where we will be sending out
test emails to our staff to see how
they're responding to some of our
training
to see how they're responding to threats
that that we would normally see on the
network
and we can then target training groups
of users that
might not necessarily have picked up
some of the message
so at the moment like i said we are
progressing quite well um
and we can hopefully continue to in the
future thank you
any questions
thank you madam chair um
i note that you're currently tracking 10
risks
in promat yes and then in 7.3.1
you say we're tracking nine cyber
security risks are we talking about two
different things
no so we classify things inside pro map
we have the ability to mark items as
cyber security or it risks so
most of most of those nine are marked as
cyber security but we have ten in there
one of them is around the um the users
can policies etc that we do
classify cyber security as well but it
is a wide variety of less
what what are the sort of security risks
that you have listed
we risked them as quite broadly so there
will be items like
um users falling prey to phishing
the users might might be performing prey
to scams we might have something in
there around
an intrusion upon our network or data
loss
within each one of those then we will be
tracking individual items inside that so
for example if there's a scam we might
have something around
something that we might call whaling
where higher level employees or
board members might be targeted so we
would be then looking at how we would
mitigate risks against that
so inside each one of those risks we
might have a mitigation that would say
that we provide training or we will
provide male filtering systems
to mitigate some of those
any other questions counselors involved
no um if if i may
have chair and really appreciate the
work that owen
is leading on behalf of the organisation
and
and i think you may have seen some media
coverage in the last
few weeks about the number of
significant hacks that have occurred
across
corporate systems in new zealand
and australia which have caused
wide-scale
disruption um i know
i'm still waiting for an oven from
fisher and paikal who
it took them weeks to recover from a
from a hack that pretty much locked down
their whole
system and whether that's either
um hack or ransomware that is occurring
from
uh international sources those risks are
are really quite real and and have major
consequences so
the work we do while as a user we can
sometimes feel frustrated that
why the heck do i need an i.t
administrator to update my next app or
what have you add multi-function
authentication which is
you know that's an email and i'll come
and you'll get a message on your phone
to say yes
i approve uh access uh being granted so
verified through two methods uh that we
are who we say we are
they're all they are all good things
there to protect us and for the
corporate uh business that we run which
is a complex business if we were without
our systems
that would significantly impact our
ability to deliver so
the inconvenience and effort that we
have to go to
to keep this issue at the forefront of
our mind is well worth it and i really
do actually appreciate the work that
owen is
leading on behalf of our team although
from our user point of view you sort of
grumble
that's the natural response it is
actually very much in our best interest
that this is occurring and
i'm pleased to see the results and and
the continuing work in this space
thank you counselor
hi owen um i just wanted to just draw
attention to
something that really stood out to me in
your report i guess it's on page
84 for us and page 3 of yours that's
4.3 the sam for compliance progress
and i just really want to give a really
big shout out to you for
that outstanding result we've
improved or held our own on every single
measure
and we've basically blown away the
benchmark scores on every measure
and that is a testament to the amazing
work that you're doing so thank thank
you to be fair that that was based upon
some work that um that was carried out
by my predecessor as well
but we have continued to improve upon
that as well as we progressed through
that's why you're the best in the
business here
thank you thank you any other
questions all right could we have a
mover of
um uh councillor williams
we'll move the recommendation and
i'm and council award will second
councillor williams now i think it's a
good report
and um my counselor mailing was saying
on 4.3
that's good good progress thank you
councilwood any further comment
on mr man just briefly um i i totally
endorsed what the ceo
uh said before and and look there was a
lack of questions because we actually
had a fairly good discussion on this uh
and workshop
last week so thank you very much owen
for the work you've done that's
mentioned
as as well your predecessor in this role
he certainly had some
um interesting presentations he did with
us and and various things to
to heighten that's awareness because as
many have mentioned we see it and we go
oh
dear but it's actually incredibly
important so i know that you're looking
to work with us as elected members more
to make sure that these compliance i do
encourage all my colleagues to make sure
that we do
take up that it is important as jim's
well mentioned rent somewhere and other
things are out there gosh i get lots of
phishing emails most days
from various sources including one that
went for me encouraging you all to buy
um itunes cards apparently so um
um and a lot of you called me back to
see if you how many you wanted me to buy
no no but anyway it's really important
that we're in this space so thanks for
the work that you do
thank you thank you
any other comments no it's been moved
and seconded then i'll
i'll put it all those in favor please
say i'm
against uh to clear it carrot thank you
owen
right we've had a request to advance the
consideration of
enterprise north canterbury so these
poor people
don't have to sit around for another
hour before we um
before we discuss it so i'm proposing
that we we
with your indulgence counsellors that we
move to item 5.6
and invite enterprise north canterbury
uh to the table to talk through the
statement of intent
thank you and that is pages
one three four two one six three
on your agenda
all right now who's going to lead us off
here
simon
i'll just hand over to heather because
the key item for your consideration is
the draft
promotions plan uh the other two items
um or you'll be familiar with them
therefore uh receipt so without further
ado
thank you heather thank you and welcome
um
i'm sorry it's lovely to be here and see
you all today and we've got a lot on
your plate so we'll try and keep this
brief as well
um each year we present the district
promotion plan
to the board and i presented it in may
and they approved it but of course it
comes to this
forum for final approval and sign off
it's a contract that we've had with the
waimakariri district council since 2005
and it covers four key areas
one around district promotion
visitor attraction event promotion
and running the eyesight so they're the
four key
areas in the business plan
with the covert we tended and we have
incorporated in our enc business plan
and along
this one as well saying that we are in
first in response mode
and in recover mode and repositioning
mode
the response we are still
reaching out to businesses as they're
reaching out to us so the enc
business support team has worked with
over 657
businesses in the last four months talk
about
fatigue so we've had to put all of our
focus on business support
uh so janine worked with those in the
visitor industry
alyssa worked with those in the food and
beverage industry and
miles guy and tanya took over the rest
and we had mel in kaikoura so
for those 657 businesses that reached
out to us
we think that's going to continue the
government just announced another
for 40 million excuse me that will go
towards
business recovery so we know that there
is still uncertain times ahead
um the recover part of this business
plan for the promotion of the district
is around the cycle trails
and itineraries to the domestic market
but it's also around the business
attraction side and business promotion
side of things where
miles has been absolutely inundated
with business startup requests
for support so a lot of people are
looking at a change of direction
either through redundancy or just
wanting to
start a business so we've had more
interactions over the last three months
looking for people looking to start a
business
than in the last year the repositioning
is what you're going to be hearing from
vanessa shortly and that is the visitor
strategy
it was from 2010 to 2015
so that has now expired so it gives us
another chance to refocus on
what's the future five years in the
visitor attraction
role um just with regard to
business um promotion um we
are still looking to target investment
in the region that's one of i mean we
work with developers and we act as first
point of contact for all new business
inquiries whether it be start up a
business
a business relocation but the ones that
we
are prominently working to develop
investment in the region which still is
the water park
um an observatory may not be oxford now
but there's certainly talk of an
observatory
and um we've still got our application
into the crown infrastructure
fund for the wheels to wiper project
we're also with the food and beverage
project which only started in the middle
of covert the first of april
we're developing we're getting a lot of
uptake for the food and beverage
producers of north canterbury we've got
a new brand it's called made
north canterbury and that's been funded
by the government
with support from the council funding as
well and
there's a lot of interest in a makers
trail for north canterbury as well
so the visitor attraction program and
i've got janine here if there's any
questions
is around our cycle preparedness we know
that the cycle
lane over the motorway bridge is going
to open
end of december early january and we
want to be ready for that and that's
connecting the existing cycle lanes in
our district
so this isn't the wheels to wiper this
is our own district here in the
waimakariri
and getting signage and working in
partnership with the key stakeholders
being ecan council
and um the tra the true high torah
trust on the park
so we're then going to develop a
cycleway campaign when that's ready and
we know that there's a reference group
about to meet
um soon as cyclones and around the cycle
and walking strategy
a domestic camp marketing that we've
signed off in this particular
the promotion plan is around supporting
kaiapoi's destination kai for jingle and
getting people on board with that
that was their initiative but enc's been
very much
a supporter in assisting them with that
and our itineraries and further
development
will continue to operate the eyesight
um the two eye sights in christchurch
have
been put into hibernation the one at
christchurch city
and at the airport so we're getting a
lot of um
business from the lack of information
services in christchurch people are
actually
driving out to kaiapoi as well
uh plus there's no booking agent there's
no travel agent in kaiapoi
either now no um place to book a bus or
a book train or booker
anything except at the eyesight so we're
actually
uh busy again
um the events promotion continues to be
really successful with lucy as well
she's
got our events fund a calendar on over
27 facebook local
facebook pages and christchurch facebook
pages so
you know we're using the social media
channels and that continues to be a
focus for us
um we have 48 000 in our budget for
event funding this year and i think this
can be a strong uptake this year and we
want to keep investing
in and growing new and existing
events that council fund that and we
administer it
and um yeah if there are any questions
to the promotion plan put to the council
this year i'd be
happy and originally to take those
questions
and just one question on the overall
district
promotion strategy and not everybody
cycles
and when kai pointed the research on
brands who spend money in our district
a lot of it was the older couple without
children
who drive um so i just wondered what are
you doing in that space
in terms of craft art museums shopping
hospitality cafe restaurants
particularly like a day trip to oxford
all those sort of areas because
that to me seems like a market that has
money they spend money
and they have disposable income and we
should attract them more from
christchurch which is our main market
yeah very good question um so i'm
working on itineraries as well so
at the moment i'm going out and visiting
the businesses i want to hear what
their stories are what they're doing
what they wanted to get out of this
and also seeing where the natural
connections are to create some really
good
itineraries for people so they you know
don't have to think about it it's just
done there for them
so in the first instance there will be
suggested itineraries and then we'll
move on to looking at commissionable
itineraries as well
yeah so yeah definitely the cars i mean
we had a wee giggle over covered and we
called them bubble car trips but
people envisioned bubble cars so yeah
we'll move away from that here
did you want to speak with smith look
just very briefly i'm certainly not
trying to cut off the
question and answer but we're going to
spend the thick end of five
hours on this topic tomorrow in terms of
the visitor strategy so just
may i ask you to just hold your
questions about the
bigger wider picture because there'll be
plenty of time tomorrow
to explore that in a lot more detail and
i say that only
in recognising that you've still got
quite a big agenda
before you thank you council award
just a question um what is happening
um and how are we resolving connecting
the cycleways
over the main highways i.e pegasus would
end
i think that's a question for the
council yeah
that's all about roadways when it comes
to roads um it's
so where i sit and i nag and i just keep
on
showing where the cycleways are and i
have a nice little map here
um that shows all yes oh well um oh
thank you all the um
uh the gaps so it's all done there and
it's just a matter of really working
when this reference group comes together
and discussing all those gaps but i'll
pass you around these maps
yes i think council it's it's top of the
agenda for
when the um cycle reference group
the massive group that it is actually
comes together
and i've asked um joey nickrook bride
when is
it going to have its first meeting and
i'm just waiting for a reply
um councilman atkinson
and then that's redmond at the risk of
breaching simon's rules i won't be there
tomorrow so
um
i do have a question well i met with uh
both then i had a chance meeting
with um the motor home association
uh in wellington last week and
the major question that he raised for us
is of course now with events and
certainly within new zealand
they look for parking spaces to be able
to go to events and
park their motor homes up there the big
problem that they are having
is actually getting the information out
of districts of where these
events are held do we supply the
motorhome association
with events in which they could attend
understanding is we don't but yeah no
me yep um so no we don't at the moment
but i'm going at the eyesight is always
um
talking with the council to provide
something that's really
comprehensive for that exactly that
reason
for people so yeah but we can certainly
start sending
the events calendar to the motorcycle oh
sorry that end sorry
just to respond to council awards
comment the woody
residents association presented at the
kaiapoi to a kiwi board last night
and also the woody and sefton community
bought the week before
on a proposed or their proposal for a
cycleway between wood end
and kaya for using a paper road
away from the main highway so i don't
know have you had any contact from them
regarding that proposal
no but i definitely know that they would
like that and that actually came up last
night at a
meeting we were at um that people would
like to be able to cycle from pegasus or
um the roundabout down through wooden to
kaiapoi
because that would then actually
complete the passchendaele and the
wooden path loop
but there is needs to be more awareness
that people actually can then
cycle actually from the pegasus
roundabout out to
pegasus bay and get onto that to hydera
coastal track
to come safely into kaiapoi fire it's a
bit further obviously
down the coastal track but to make that
a better ride and clearer
um we can actually use that as step one
rather than
build a cycle lane down the motorway or
beside the motorway
so there is actually a cycle lane that
people can use to get from
pegasus roundabout to kaiapoi but it's
not well mapped out
i think obviously
looking at those options agreed i mean
if it's a if it's a
commuter cyclist they're not going to
want to go out there
and that the commuter cyclist was the
best option or the option that the
council chose
from the bridge to kaiapoi which is
straight past hellas so
it would be the same as going guy boy to
wood end in the same manner where it
goes alongside the road
and uses the whereas our our whole
promotion is around the recreational
safe family walking and cycling routes
on another topic altogether going back
to your response
function i know you guys have been
really flat out working with
with businesses in that since the the
covid issue has raised its head
but i was just curious have you had much
to do or much interaction with
businesses in oxford or in and around
there
i just went out to visit them a couple
of weeks ago because i felt that we've
been very
reactive and entrenched
so as the chief executive it's actually
nice to go out and go and meet them
face to face are they happy with our
service have they any other requirements
or needs so yes i did visit ten
businesses
in oxford obviously the supermarket nz
lulu
my favorite shop him is um jams
which is just newly set up the chemist
cafe 51 yeah i went pretty much
door-to-door the sheffield pie shop
and they're actually all in very good
heart excellent they might like to
report
thank you i also went to cheviot and did
the same thing
up there and they're actually doing very
well as well but they're very
unfortunate where two of their cafes
have closed down so two rivers is closed
and the paddocks is for sale
um so it's close so the cheviot tea
rooms is doing a booming
business right now thank you did you
want to comment someone just wanted to
if there are questions
i just wanted to highlight for um
and it's the results of customer
satisfaction
and we've seen it
activity in the declined and um
um
thank you i do have a question myself
which is is on azure
cool the last audit and risk committee
in march
there was quite extensive talk about
combining
market view data and crafting
some performance indicators and and
i was very keen that it go into the
statement of intent for
enc i note that there isn't anything
here um but there is you've got a
briefing
simon um later in the meeting can you
clarify um and and that
is talking about the data i'm i'm
interested in bringing into
an soi but so can you clarify exactly
where we are with that is it intended
that
this is reported separately and we tick
off
um easy
is
performance
yes so the market view data
well i'm not going to leap ahead with
the briefing but
you're bringing going to bring the
market view data and whatever data that
enc is is collecting um on
post covert or response and recovery and
that sort of stuff
how is that going to come to the origin
risk in the
future
yes this is the subject
um
okay thank you um any other questions
from the councillors in the interests of
so um can i have a a
mover council award will move
the mayor or second the recommendations
gus lord
thank you heather for a great report
i've had quite a bit of working with you
over the last few months and your team
and i know that you work
under really confined budget but you do
an amazing job for us in the district
and i want to say thank you to you and
your team and
let you know that you have our total
support and anything you want to do
you're doing a great job
and a difficult situation and thank you
to everybody
for doing super job thank you
endorse those comments uh speaks for
itself on the report
uh thank you heather and the team are
fortunate on the board
of vnc so i know exactly what goes on in
the operation
and and how hard the organisation works
okay for the time connect responding and
connecting with businesses through
covert and your continuing connection
there over 700 businesses as i
understand
it was very impressive and i know that
it's been very valued
by those businesses that they've reached
out in
in some instances provided cash flow
advice where they've needed or other
advice
and just connecting with them actually i
had a number that contacted me and i
put them in touch with you and i know
that they appreciated
that follow-up i also appreciate the
work that
you do in following up very direct
matters like i know there was a measure
a couple of weeks ago
it's been circulating around a potential
vape store
in runyora and i appreciate it that
you've been with me and the building
owner
and i know there's been others that have
also followed that up as well
i spoke with the potential new tenant
on sunday who was delighted with the
assistance
and encouragement they'd had i know
councillor water had also been very
active and her encouragement to them
and my understanding is they're now
going to sign at least that's a very
real
matter in our town in our towns we're
encouraging businesses to be here but
the right sort of businesses i've got
nothing against people that they
absolutely nothing but not in that
location
when we've spent so much money and
investment there and we're also
attracting
um people out here that are coming out
here the miraval shoppers and other
shoppers that are coming out
to cairport to running or to oxford
because they like that shopping
experience that they get
that boutique store so protecting that's
really important so
we we can't directly control that but we
can give every encouragement so heather
appreciate
uh the work that you and your team have
done in that space
and thoroughly endorse the
recommendation thank you
any other comments councils no
counsellor mood any any
additions no all right um we'll put
um the recommendations um as outlined on
page whatever it is
134 and all those in favor please
against declare it carried
thank you very much enc and simon
and we'll obviously be in touch to
see you again tomorrow thank you
uh so we went back to um the
sustainability
strategy on page what page is that on
here
95 on your diligent but in fact it's
only
kidding you know it is here 95 on this
this running sheet so welcome um
mike to the table to take us through the
third quarter report
and um over to you thank you
okay good morning um okay i i won't be
too long with this i don't think
but it's just really to say this is the
third of of uh four
quarterly reports on the sustainability
strategy implementation
process
and just know not even in our
recommendations that we've added
something from last time and
this is something some work that uh
simon simon markham has been
is addressing around the standard report
template been updated and
to include reference to sustainability
consideration so that's a work in
progress
um just just a couple of other things
i'd say like to say too that
we have been working on a number of
issues around
on the site covert 19 hasn't helped
but we've we've uh certainly got in
place
the organics landfill recyclable bins
and pro
in in place ready to go when when such
time is
ready where and also the earthquake
repairs here hasn't helped
certainly with the kitchens first and
then we'll look at the wider
organization
um and just to note too that
item there 4.6 back in early july the
council meeting we did appoint
at least the two councilor members of
the steering group for the
sustainability strategy
and so that's that's a key part of of of
uh where we're going to
in the stage two of the strategy so
that's the thing that we're overlapping
here
we're talking about what we've done and
we're talking about what we're doing but
with
this sort of a necessary overlap there
um
just just briefly i'd like to sort of
add something sort of practical here
that um
what um ashley and and the aim team has
provided me with some data to show that
you know like back in october december
the first quarter we were spending
something like 52 000
per quarter on fuel that dropped to 28
000 in the cobit period so that's
yeah april to june so that's kind of it
just shows what what
um what can happen and we sort of still
business was able to progress
without so many cars being used so it's
just a just an interesting sort of
observation anyway that we use a lot
less fuel
whether we'll be able to maintain that
i'm not sure uh
and just yeah that's pretty well it i
think i take it everyone's had managed
to have a look at the report and i'm
just happy to take any
questions any questions
councillor barnett um just quickly mike
thank you for the very very good report
but
i just wondered what some of the items
you've got action complete when it's
actually been moved to another
department
perhaps that should be just stated moved
on
rather than complete for example the
council-wide
opportunities developing an urban and
rural forestry strategy
that's his action complete but it's not
it's just been moved to another
department
okay yes i see what you mean as it
stated there it possibly has
completed but yeah it's um it's moved to
it and it's changed it's moved into
something else a little bit too so and
that's certainly going to be something
that's going to be picked up but more so
and then in the next strategy
any further questions councils council
redmond
well justin gorsuch councillor barnett
had said
i noticed some of the um refurbishment
issues
with this building a down is complete
because that project is
on hold at the moment where it's not
really completed it's just an advance
okay anymore yes thank you any more
questions before we move
no you're you're moving
yeah yes thank you councilman
just very quickly it's an excellent
report mike thank you very very much for
this
i understand you've had a major
disruption with the kova 19 and so
therefore
it will be group good now the steering
group has established that you can move
forward
and refine this to turn it into more of
an action plan and we can see some
things on the ground
i'm i'm desperate to put my tea bags
somewhere other than the rubbish in the
kitchen
so um i look forward to seeing some of
these smaller action plans
actually going forward thank you take it
home and put it on your garden
um no any other
comments answers no all right
we'll put the recommendations all those
in favor please say aye
against the cleric carried thank you
very much
and the next one is
the visitor strategy pages 104-133
and welcome vanessa and simon
if you want to rip through this that'll
be good
hi everyone i'll take my report as read
a couple of quick points
this strategy is just for five years
through to 2025
enc are providing the 15k budget for it
out of an overflow surplus from their
2018-19
events budget line we're looking at just
limited community engagement
on 22 july and august 24. as opposed to
going out for full public consultation
given the relatively niche nature of
this strategy and the fact that we sort
of need to manage expectations around
what we can deliver on being that we are
low in resourcing for this for the next
five years
and likely budget as well and it's
primarily um
targeting uh efforts enc's towards
marketing in the future
and councils in terms of public realm
investments anything that we may
decide to enhance to basically make that
visitor experience much more
attractive i think that's the main point
so i'm happy to take any questions
questions
no you're you'll move it
yes just thoroughly endorsed this
approach we have to do this
everything has changed and we're going
to have to look at this through a
completely fresh lens
so i hope that the exercises we're doing
going forward will actually
be open to the fact that we almost have
to start at the drawing board
our visitors are going to be completely
different they're going to
demand a different experience because of
the loss of all the international
visitors
and we are going to be competing with a
lot of people who have much higher
budgets than us
so i look forward to reviewing this
budget with you
councilor i look forward to working with
you because
it's going to be really positive out
there and we're going to really nail it
so
looking forward to the next week
working on things thank you
atkinson uh thank you madam chair i
actually endorse this too i think that
it is something i think starting from
the absolute beginning would be an
absolute mistake
the other thing is that uh we've always
had a high number of day visitors in
in our district we don't rely on
international visitors
that's where our focus should be and
it's always been to my view
and should actually be in the next five
years because the international ones
probably won't be there in saying that
we also need to be ready
that within two or three years if indeed
things do clear up out here
we might have a lot less population to
be able to move around but
um if it does clear up there in the next
two or three years we need to be nimble
enough to move on that
and our district is growing into
something that is internationally
called attractive to people the wide
open spaces and the
the areas in which we have so i want to
see that it is continues to focus
on that day market that we have as we
have always done
and this is being reported in just about
every media story that there is at the
moment
the shop local and in fact what retail
is doing
in the first week after covert returned
of people shopping locally actually
put people up 12 turnover in retail
that is massive now we already
concentrate on that
i don't want to see too much change in
this to be honest because we already do
that
it's how we bolster it and make it
happen better so it's not
actually about a change of culture
that's what we do
we just need to make it better and try
and concentrate more on what we're doing
rather than try and reinvent the will
thank you any other points
just write a reply and my comments
related to the fact that new zealanders
have to travel in new zealand
and that's a completely different
scenario from what we've been facing
in previous years where most of a lot of
those people would spend that money
overseas
so therefore we have that opportunity to
grab that market
if we do this right so therefore i think
we are going to have to
keep our minds open as to ways we can
actually
get some leverage of new zealanders
traveling in new zealand
bearing in mind we're also going into
what looks like a global economic crisis
so i think we're going to have to be
smarter than we have in the past
build on what we've got but behave have
an open mind
about new opportunities and i hope this
council will be progressive in that
space
thank you any other comments counsellors
no we'll um put the um
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say i'm
against the cleric carrot thank you very
much
now we've gone we've done item 5.6 we'll
move on to
item six which is the portfolio
updates and council award with your
audit list long term plan an excellent
program
thank you um
with the audit and risk we live streamed
in may
um i've also we've been looking at the
civic precinct put out
plans and design that's coming along
lighting town center feature lighting
we've had two
two people submit ideas we've got a
third one coming this week so then we'll
be able to make
an assessment on who we might take along
with us to design
our future town center lighting
um attend to the ymca job summit
um town center strategy cardboard youth
business yesterday and with the
excellence program we're all striving
every day for excellence and
we've been rewarded um with our
double a rating which is amazing the
long term plan we're just starting on
that
now that we've done the annual plan
and we're moving on that challenges
of course with the conditions of the
president's civic
precinct building and the fact that
staff are now in 12 different buildings
is not cohesive and is quite disruptive
it needs
urgent action and i'm asking you all to
think about this very carefully
to bring forward plans and erect a new
one-stop precinct building
next to an enlarged library the risk
here is for staff retention and health
which we were talking about before and
fatigue
and they have the right um in a modern
efficient healthy working environment
a present situation is very challenging
for all
i urge your support to bring forward in
the long-term plan
the build of the library
and the civic precinct thank you
thank you councillor i don't think we're
going to perhaps decide on that right
now but thank you
thank you for the encouragement and
putting it front and center
thank you uh any questions of council
award
yes counselor just just a little one um
you were talking about the lighting
plans
um for wear
lighting oh
a committee um that um that is um
is looking at the lighting time centers
for carpooling
and um we've had two two people present
their thoughts and we're having a third
person on thursday
our concept plans and then we will
choose we've only got a budget i think
to to advise us and to do some plans
for a lighting strategy for the two
towns moving forward
so is that like as in a decorative type
thing
or is it just i think safety
it's no it's decorative it's um it's
enhancing the buildings enhancing the
towns and making the towns
feel really special so that people feel
really good about
being in that space and feel good about
staying in that space and spending their
money
because i was gonna say the i know the
lights are quite expensive items but
just the fairy lights on the trees at
night in rangiora and and the lights in
kaiapoi
um especially like whenever you're
sitting there by the water they're just
beautiful
and they really do enhance the feel of
both places so
um yeah it's good to see something like
that being looked at it'll come
to either ltp or um
just wanted to ask the question
go on with your meeting now thank you
um councillor barna communications and
customer service
thank you yes and emma just noted i've
emailed this to you at dot points to
help you with the minutes
um communications because we didn't have
an audit meeting this is reporting from
the first quarter
which is january to march 2020 there
were eight communication
plans written 53 media inquiries
and 58 news stories plus five public
consultations
our website had over users
independent users and the key topics of
interest were the curbside recycling
that has a big impact on the
communications customer service area
and also the rates lately which was
probably covered related with them
but at the end of march facebook has
over
73 000 users
who viewed our posts and video views are
up over
100 more recently in communications
uh they've been very busy with the
ranger of service center communications
and also have worked on the
aa lgp council rating release as the
mayor mentioned
we've also just rolled out an e-news
newsletter so i encourage you to let
everybody know and encourage them to
sign up
in customer services recently they're
very busy with dog registrations
which you can now do online and there's
a few little gremlins in the system but
you can actually register your drug
online
if that's all you need to do that's
brilliant and the one july rates demand
has just hit letterboxes
so the phone calls have started to be
very busy in customer services
and they're also very busy with rate
rebate appointments at the moment
the service request responsiveness group
are meeting again this week
and there'll be an update on that soon
and
customer services have also assisted
with the cemetery strategy which is
almost ready
and hopefully coming to council in
august
thank you any questions of council about
it
no thank you we now move on